[Music]
thanks so much for tuning in today to
talk about
managing packages for open source data
science
my name is alex and i'm a solution
engineering manager here
at rstudio um just a little about me so
that you sort of
know who i am and why i'm talking about
this i'm a former data scientist
and a data science team lead uh i worked
on sort of healthcare politics economic
policy kinds of issues when i was a
full-time data scientist and since
coming to our studio i've been a
solution engineer here for about
two years so that's that's me um
so let's let's dive right in and talk
about managing packages so
you know data science is a lot like this
delicious sandwich um this sandwich
looks incredible by the way if you know
how to make the sandwich like
let me know because wow but anyway
dude aside's a little like like making a
delicious sandwich maybe it's an app
that you're making maybe it's an api
a report or a scheduled job and it takes
a little bit of planning a little
preparation
and a little skill to make something
really really great um
today we're going to talk about sort of
one important aspect of the open source
data science which is which is package
management
and so we'll start talking about how
like package management can screw up
your plans to make
beautiful delicious sandwiches or data
science products
um some background on sort of how it all
works and then finally some thoughts on
like
how it can be better and how it doesn't
have to always be so painful
so let's let's dive right in so first
you know sort of sort of the pain
um so one reason this can be painful is
that
folks are blocked right you're blocked
from installing packages either you
don't have permissions to install on
your machine
um or you're blocked from public package
sources like crayon bio connector pipe
and that's that's a big problem or you
have no way to share
private packages and i i will say that
you know there are some organizations
that have
um you know bans against installing
stuff to your own machine
and there's sort of no way around that
but hopefully what you come out of this
presentation with is some information on
sort of
how to work with your it team to to get
to a situation to do what the work that
you really need to do
um and sort of that leads into the
situation of
it feeling like i t and data science are
at odds and this isn't so surprising
right like data scientists
want the software they want and they
want it when they want it um
and that's not necessarily always it's
concern right itr admins have a lot of
concern about platform stability and
security
um and and those things don't have to be
at odds but but they can be and so
i don't think that that could be a
problem there's the issue of fragility
um you know when you're sharing your
project with somebody else are you
confident that they'll be able to open
it up
and actually use it or or you know might
they open it up and find themselves
stuck because they don't have the right
package set
and then lastly sort of like when you
come back to a project in the future
right like this is just a form of
sharing with future you
but how confident are you that like your
package set hasn't changed in the
meantime and you can sort of get back to
the same
state and so to be completely clear like
you can't fix all these problems and
particularly if you're just a lone data
scientist it may not be possible to fix
all these you may need some
some help from others at your
organization but you can set yourself up
for success here
um and so let's let's talk a little bit
about how
i i love to cook um and and when you're
talking about cooking there's this
concept called misenplace which means
uh like putting in place in french i
think that's my understanding i don't
speak french
um but you know what it what it's really
about is you know you sort of cut
measure and prep all of your ingredients
before you ever turn on your stove right
so like
by the time you're sort of turning on
the gas by the time you're starting to
cook
you know everything is in place and sort
of ready to go
by by that time and so you know one of
the reasons that like you can't
guarantee outcomes but but you can
really guarantee
your your process and so um that's what
sort of the the misen plus step is meant
to do when you're cooking and and
you can do something very similar right
package management
is very much like the mise-en-place of
doing data science right it's getting
all your ingredients all your things in
place
before you go so let's let's take a step
back and talk a little bit about like
how do the ingredients get there in the
first place
and and how do you make sure they're
ready to go when you're doing data
science we're going to stick with this
this metaphor so your food starts at the
grocery store right it's like packaged
up it's on the shelf it's ready to go
and you you go and get it and then
when you want to cook something you go
and buy the right ingredients and you
bring them home
to to your pantry right there's this
shopping process you go and you fill
your shopping cart
you pay for it you you take it home and
it's it's very similar for packages
um so you know that's the the this you
know shopping thing where the stuff gets
from the grocery store to
to your pantry and it's really the same
for for packages for packages you know
your grocery store is
is your repository so this is sort of an
external place
where you have all of your packages and
they're
stored sort of ready for you to go in an
inert way
and then there's your library and that
is sort of your pantry where you keep
your packages that are
just for you and the things you're going
to make um
and and and that's that's how that works
and so for many teams
the the repository that they use is
public right it might be
public cran public bioconductor public
package manager
um other teams choose to maintain
private repositories our studio package
manager mini crayon something else
that's really fine
but the libraries are always private and
the libraries are you know anywhere
there's a kitchen anywhere there's
actual
r or python processes running in the ide
in a notebook on our studio connect in a
docker container right there's a library
attached to that and the shopping
process is the install right so the the
sort of packages get from the grocery
store repository into your
um private pantry library via the
install
it'll just be a little more like precise
about this uh you know i have these two
sort of side by side but like really the
way this works is that like
like the grocery store and pantries many
libraries
are served by one repository right one
repository
um provides packages for for many
libraries so let's let's dive in a
little bit on like
how that works so a repository is just a
file server has a bunch of directories
indexed in a particular way
um and so just to be precise right like
this is the link you'll note it's a url
right it's a real like link to an
internet
site for a particular package on crayon
right now cran is the
main r uh package repository public one
and so what you'll see here right is
like this is for windows uh
it is using the development version of
our our version 4.1
it is for the a3 package which i chose
because it is the alphabetically first
package on
crayon and it's version 1.0.0 and so
this is
like literally this is the directory
structure um
inside the crayon repository and so this
is just a directory
that sort of organizes this particular
way
that are when you go to install a
package it knows how to sort of
walk this tree and get the package and
the package versions
that you need one of the other important
aspects of the repository is that the
repository is
not local it is almost never the case
that your repository is on the same
machine
as where you're actually doing your work
very often the repository is going to be
like
actually in the cloud it's actually
going to be a website like a you know
like that url i just showed you
um or sometimes it's going to be an
internal networked server
but usually even if you're doing work on
like rstudio server
it's almost never going to be on the
same server it's going to be a different
server
that's very much in contrast to the
library the library is just a directory
but it's on the same machine as the
running r process
um and so you'll see like this is a
linux path
to you know inside my home directory
it's the rx
8664 you know linux library um
and you'll see like this is specific to
our version 4.1
and uh the a3 package and so you know
the one of the big differences here
is that libraries are specific to the
version of r
they are not specific to the package
version and this is because
like r needs a way to resolve
definitively
to a particular package and in
particular the thing that arises here is
like
some people wonder like oh why couldn't
you just have a package here and the
reason is that like
then when a3 has dependencies that it
needs to go get right it needs to be
able to at some level fetch those by
name right it needs to just get the
version
that's there and not uh maintain many
versions
at once and so this is the the distinct
one of the big distinctions
between the repository and the library
is that the library has at most
one version of any package the
repository has many versions of each
package and even many versions for
different operating systems
um and and and in in in either case
uh you have like the thing that ties it
all together is your your settings on
your machine right that tells you
your r or python process what repository
to use what library to use that sort of
thing and so
one thing i want to make really clear is
that like this is the same
for rn python there are some minor
differences in tooling which we'll get
to in just a moment
but everything i've talked about so far
and most everything i'm going to talk
about for the rest of this webinar
is identical in r and python the sort of
conceptual way that repositories
and libraries house packages is exactly
the same
in r and python so let's let's get a
little into the nitty-gritty here
of like how these package installs
actually work
in r and python so let's say i go to
install a package uh in r i do that with
install.packages in python i do that
with pip install package
and you'll notice like the here is one
of the differences which is that in
r i do all of my actual package
management and installation from
inside r right i type install that
packages at a running r
interpreter that's different in python
uh in python you use a
separate binary to manage your your
um your package installs most often
that's pip it can also be something like
conda
um but uh you know it's it's a either
way it's a separate thing from your
running python process you don't do this
in a python interpreter you do this at
the command line and so
that's a difference in tooling but in
terms of what they what these
tools do they're conceptually identical
so in either case what they're going to
do is they're going to look at your sort
of
settings in particular in r it's going
to look at your options repos
uh in in python it's going to look at
your pip config
and uh you know from there it's going to
find the url of a repository remember
this is going to be a real url
either on the internet or a networked um
you know
server and from there it's going to move
that package into your
particular library now when i go to
actually
load a package either or python right i
do that in r with the
library package command in python i do
it with import package
and so what i'm going to do from there
is i'm going to or what our python are
going to do
are they going to look at the in r the
dot libpaths or in python the syst.path
hopefully you've never had to look at
these before because they just resolve
automatically
from that our python will know which
library to look to and we'll bring that
back into your running our python
environment and then you can use the
functions from
those packages so you know this was a
lot of nitty-gritty in-depth stuff
um and you know if if this if this all
felt
like this was really exciting and
intrigued you like congratulations
you're a huge nerd and you're in great
company so
delighted to have you here but you know
if this sort of like went over your head
a little bit or like didn't feel that
important that's great
that's totally fine you should never
need to manage this directly but i i
share all this mainly to make the point
that you can see why this is a little
bit frustrating why there's no sort of
like
single silver bullet to make this all
work
um successfully managing a package
environment requires you know
at least three different components
right it requires the repository
the library and the settings that tie it
all together right all three of those
things need to work
and so there's no single silver bullet
to make this all just just work that
said
oops there is a happy path it is
possible to make this delicious sandwich
whatever it is and it's not even that
hard
but it's it's you know you're going to
want to do some planning up front you're
going to want to do your visa plus
and so we're going to talk for the rest
of this talk about two ways
that you can make this better and the
first is to develop a package management
plan
with your it department and the second
is
project specific libraries um that you
can manage as an individual data
scientist
and so from here we're going to get to
the package management prime directive
which is a little grandiose but
i like the slide so there we go um
and so the first is that you know
repository should be as broad as
possible right these
should be managed centrally if they're
being managed at all and they should try
and serve as many users as possible
that is the opposite from libraries
which are specific um one other thing i
should mention about libraries is that
they are pull
only right you have to pull packages to
your libraries and so
you know that means that the data
scientists should have control of what
they pull
into their own libraries this is
sometimes a point of friction between it
teams
and data scientists and it's it's worth
sort of
um you know having a conversation with
your it team about how
you can safely manage libraries as the
data science team because we see many
many people doing it quite successfully
so to to take you know dive in a little
bit on that like who manages each of
these things so
on your repository like you don't
necessarily need to manage a repository
a lot of organizations choose not to
manage a repository and we'll get a
minute into
why you might want to but many
organizations choose
not to manage a repository if you are
going to manage one
that's generally on it or admins and you
know sometimes you have data scientists
serving in this role of sort of the the
data science platform admin
and that's fine but it's good to
distinguish what you're doing as a data
science platform admin
versus as a data scientist and so most
often we see
it admins managing their repository
because the job here is you know to
stand up a server
to network it correctly to make sure
that it's available to users to make
sure that it stays up has the
appropriate amount of stability and
security
and so these are really it admin tasks
in terms of managing the repository
on the library side that really falls to
the data scientists to manage either a
user level library or increasingly and
as i'm going to suggest to do here
a project level library right an
individual library that corresponds to a
single project
is the safest path because then you know
that even if you do other projects you
won't have to worry about breaking
your project library and then the
settings that tie them together right
like if you're on a server like our
studio server
this most often is administered by the
it or the admin if you're on the desktop
this is usually administered by the
individual
data scientist
and so you know then the question is
like how
how do you manage this what are the
tools that you use so on the repository
level um
you know obviously we recommend using
rstudio package manager as the package
repository for
crayon bioconductor and pi pi
repositories
um there are also open source products
like mini crayon that you can use if
that's what your organization
or you prefer on the library sorry
there's there's rn and virtual
environment and this is another
difference between r and python in in
our lan
um you know the the two options that
most people use do this are either pack
rat or rn
rn is a full replacement for packrat and
in fact it was written by the same
person
so if you're using packrat upgrade to rn
if you're not managing projective
libraries start doing it
use rn on the python side there are a
ton of options for how to do this
there's virtual end there's condo
there's pi end
there's all these different things
and if your organization has a standard
that's fine use what you want to use
um but if if you aren't using anything
yet i would encourage you to use
virtualenv it's it's relatively simple
um and and as far as i've seen i've seen
lots of organizations sort of
successfully use virtualenv and so
that's the one that i recommend most
often
um and you know in terms of the settings
that can be configured inside the r
studio ide if you're using the rstudio
ide
or you can use config files like our
profile or our profile dot site
or our environ or our environment site
to set
those settings great so let's talk a
little bit about
why organizations want to manage private
repositories
and the the the main reason here right
is that i
t when i t needs to control the pack set
of packages that's available to people
this is how you do it i want to
emphasize this that if
you are in an organization where you
cannot install things
install our package on your machine um
you're in
a broken state and you need to figure
out a way to convince your i.t team to
let you install stuff
it's really really hard to work in that
environment um one answer is to get a
centralized server
but but the other answer is to allow
installs only
from a private repository right so so
that's that's where we see people
standing at private repositories and
that is because they're in offline or
air gap situations that is
there's no access to the internet from
where you're installing packages now
that that's a common
sort of thing in high security
environments and that's totally fine the
solution is
to have a repository behind your
firewall
and then allow people free and open
access to that repository
and lock them from using any repository
outside the firewall
similarly if you have to validate
package sets into your environment if
that's why you can't install packages
because you you can't install sort of
anything
again the way to solve this problem is
to have the repository be the gateway
right the repository chooses
what are the sets of packages people are
allowed to install for safety or
security reasons
and and then what they can install this
can also work really well if you have
projects that require sort of
um you know package validation and then
like once this package has been
validated you can only use that set
this is a great way to administer that
right like you administer the the itier
admin administers it
at the repository level and then data
scientists are free to install whatever
packages are available to them
from the repository but they can't get
anything else all they can get is what's
in the repository
and then the last uh the last piece here
is if you're doing private
internal packages that you're developing
locally um
having a an offline repository can be a
great way to do it
so for the rest of this presentation
we're going to talk about how to do your
mise en place
with rn i'm going to talk about some of
the ways that rm can be can be helpful
here and that is by
isolating your libraries on a per
project basis which we've been talking
about sort of being a good thing
using a snapshot or repository from our
studio package manager to ensure
reproducibility later on sharing or
restoring a project when you're sharing
with a colleague or when you're coming
back to a project after some time
and how to start a new project and
easily sort of do your reason plus
to make sure that this works in a way
that you're happy with
so first let's open up this very
ominously named
package fails project here
and so you know what what i want to
point out is this
this is some code in an armored document
um it last
ran in 2018 in june
um i'm not going to get into really what
this code does and so what i'll say up
front actually is like
what this code does is pretty silly uh
so please don't judge me based on that
um what i wanted to do is i wanted to
find an example where upgrading the
package versions
would cause something to fail um and in
a tidy verse package because you know
since we make the tiny verse packages
here in our studio i figured
we could blame ourselves at least one
thing i will say is actually it was
hard to find an example of this working
uh if you saw hadley's talk at our
studio global
um you know the tidyverse team is making
a huge effort to
not break people's code it was actually
quite difficult to find an example where
this fails but
anyway so here is a here's code that ran
in 2018
and so i'm going to try and run it today
in 2021
and what we're going to find is that
this code
let me make this make us a little bigger
so it's easier to see this code no
longer runs because
the argument data is missing it looks
like it's there
so i don't know what's up i mean i do
know what's up but like
we know this is the kind of thing to
take forever to debug and sort of get
stuck here
um if the eagle eyed among you will
notice that the problem is actually this
argument was renamed to
dot data in in tidyar later and so like
if i look here what version of tidy mr
tidy are
am i running um
i am running tidy r 1.0.2
so i happen to know that as of
um as of june and let's look again at
when this last ran
this ran in june 2018 and as of june
2018
the version of tidyr back then was like
081
and so what's happened is tidy r has
gotten upgraded because i did something
else on my system that bumped the
version of tidyr
and so now my code is broken it's just
broken and that's really frustrating
right there are ways to fix this but i
got to spend time fixing it it would be
ideal if this had not happened in the
first place
so let's go to the much more friendly
named rn
working example here and what you'll see
is this is exactly the same code
identical code and this is gonna run
our markdown render boom done
and now i've got a version that
works today right like this random today
just now 217
2021 and so what's the difference
right like if if you've been paying
attention i'm sure you realize the
difference is that i'm using rn pure but
like let's real quick just check
so like inside the working version
the version of tidy r is 081 right
whereas in the non-working version it
had gotten
upgraded in a way that i didn't really
mean for it to
um so that's that's great and the way
this look to be transparent
let's check out those dot lid paths
which i mentioned was the way that um
was the way that it looks up where the
library is and so you'll see like the
library in this version
this is like my user level library
and this is the system level library so
like at some point
in my user library since 2018 i've
updated the version of tight ear which
is not
very hard to imagine on the other hand
inside this
this version that works the lid paths
point to
this is my home directory so like this
is inside the arm working
inside this project there's an rn
library that is going to be keeping sort
of this package
safe for me for later so that's that's
great like rm has done its job
i am i'm keeping myself safe so but so
that solves one problem right like my
package versions will stay consistent as
long as i keep this rn
project with um you know with
with this project so what happens now if
i want to install another package let's
see
let's say i want to install uh ggplot
now i did install package ggplot
oh great so it installed gtplat221 so
that
that's great because ggplot221 i happen
to know
is the version from june 2018.
currently gg plot 2 is on 3.3.3
which is not the version i want right
like that's too new it might break
uh so how did i get ggplot2 and of
course if i look at my options repos
that's the answer is that my repo here
is pointed
at a public r studio package manager and
and
i happen to know that this is the url
format that means that this is a dated
repo so let's look at what that means so
here's our studio package manager
this is public our studio package
manager packagemanage.rstudio.com
you can go there and use it as you wish
it's free and and available to use
and so what i'll see is that if i go
here to the setup
pane i can get if i go back to
june 2018 there's that 72
right that is from that date so what
that means that every time i install
packages
from this repository they will work
together
as of june 2018 and so i never have to
worry about installing a new version
that's going to mess things up
because they will always play nicely
together the other thing i will say and
this is again a thing that's different
between r and python
um is that uh um in r
you need to specify that you want binary
repositories for your
operating system um they're specific to
the operating system and you can change
that here
to choose the right repository this is
really important um
just because using binary repositories
can really really speed up
install times by like several orders of
magnitude and so
it's worth it to choose a a binary
repository
that's not necessary for python um
python by default will always give you
the binaries for for your system
um so anyway so okay so now we know how
i got
this um you know how this package worked
that sort of thing
why my uh my tight er works but how
about how is this being maintained
and so what rm does is arm stays what's
called a lock file
and so this lock file contains my
version of r
right it says it's our version 3.6.2
this has that repository in it right
that's that repository that i used and
so that
uh zoomed out too much
this is that repository that i had set
you know when i started this project
and then i have a list of all of my
packages what version they are what
repository they're using if i have
github packages it will record that as
well
uh and so are sorry get packages in
general not just github but also gitlab
bucket and so this gets recorded in my
lock file and so if i want to make
another project let's say i want to
share this with my with my uh
colleague right all i need to do
is i need to share the rn lock file with
them so here's what i'm going to do i'm
going to take that rn block file
and i'm going to copy it to the broken
version
so all that i've done right like this is
the version of this project that does
not work
tidy r is wrong here right uh this is
actually i got to load the data
and tidy r does not work here right this
is again that that wrong version of
titanium the new version of tidyr
and so now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to do rn vinit which will stand up
my rn
virtual environment submit it to this
project and it will restore it in
particular
from the lock file um the other thing i
just want you to notice is that was
almost instantaneous in terms of
restoring that that lock file
and the reason is uh because rn
maintains a user level cache so if i've
ever maintained if i've ever installed
these packages before
they automatically get restored and it
is super fast and so now if i go you'll
see package version
tidy r 0 8 1.
awesome now i've got the right version
now i can run this code
and it just works right so this is
really awesome and it makes an easy way
to um to share uh uh
uh you know um a lock file with
or to share a project in an environment
with somebody else or with future you
great okay so so one more question that
comes all the time it's like okay
great kind of useful like how do i do
this for a new project right like how do
i start this afresh
and so it's really quite easy when i go
to new project here in the r studio ide
new directory i'm gonna start a new
project i'm gonna call this
my new project and now all i do
is i'm going to click here use rn with
this project
and now rn is going to be set up with
this with this project as it starts
um here on on our studio server um it's
going to set up a new project for me
with my sort of folder there with my
rproj file that's the project folder
and an rn library that is attached to
the project
by default which is which is really
uh sort of a nice thing to do here now
so what this means
is that whenever you know if i if i go
to install packages
oops if i could spell it right that
would help it will install you know
again at linkedin from that cache super
super quick
um and so you know that's the part of
using rn now what if i want to use the
snapshot of a repository so there's a
little bit of judgment here around what
the date
is to choose you want to choose a date
that sort of like works for your project
my general recommendation is to choose a
date that's sort of like around the time
your project is pretty stable so you
probably don't want it to be like
the day you start the project but maybe
like when the bulk of the coding is done
and you're thinking okay it's time to
save this for later
you can do rn modify and go in here oh
here's my
my like rn block file and i can edit
let's get a repository that's like more
up to date let's say i want to do like
yesterday i can get that
get the lock file the the right
repository
i just put it in here and now when i
start a new session
it's going to automatically set my
repository to be the right repository
it's going to take just a second here to
reload
but after it reloads what you'll see is
that it's going to be that um that
updated
rstudio uh that updated version of the
the package manager repository now if i
want to say
uh the the way one other thing to be
aware of is the way to capture
dependencies is i'm going to save
i'm going to save an r file here and now
when i do rn
snapshot it's going to introspect on
those files
and it's realized that i need ggplot2 in
here and
all of its uh all of its dependencies so
this is makes it really easy to use you
can also set up auto snapshots
so that it will snapshot any anytime you
type install that packages
inside this project folder um great so
that's basically what what i wanted to
share
in terms of uh using rmv and so um
we're gonna wrap up now and so just a
couple a couple things to review here
so um the the thing you want to do right
is two things to encourage you to do
do a package management plan uh with
your
your group right how are you managing
repositories what are those settings
supposed to be the default
repos uh and and how are you managing
libraries
and before you start your individual
data science work do your meson plots
um use rn and and you know i i just
showed off how to use rn for r
the process of using virtual end with
python is really really similar
um really similar um if you want more
information about this
we have website
environments.rtstudio.com where you can
feel free to
um check out more information on this
and if you're interested in our studio
package manager if that seems like
something that your team could use
um feel feel free to send us an email at
sales rstudio.com and we can
um talk more with you there
um i'm gonna pull up the slido
questions um
okay um also interested in r studios
docker images
but they are advertised as experimental
any idea of when they will be out of
experimental um
no i i don't know that we have any plans
to make them
you know more strongly supported than
experimental now uh for for the time
being
um at this point uh you know if you want
to use them you should feel free to use
them
um but no imminent plans to stabilize
them
as as far as i know um
oh this is a great question uh somebody
asks
interested in the advice that users
should manage their own
libraries to that end what's your advice
on the role of a centrally managed
site library this is a great question i
love this question
um this is a question that
uh you know i i think a lot of it folks
um have have um
yeah it's a really good question
the short answer here is that i do not
believe it's necessary
um i i it is definitely the case i
strongly
recommend against trying to disallow
um users from being able to pull their
own packages right like use
data scientists should be able to manage
their own
specific packages for themselves um
and the reason for that is that like for
example let's say
that uh you know i have just a centrally
managed set of packages then like
somebody has to do that management right
then it has to manage that
library which can be very difficult in
terms of managing not only what packages
but what
versions what's installed what date was
it installed how does that correspond to
the project right it gets
really complicated really really fast
and so i strongly recommend
against having all the packages in a
centrally site managed library
so there's another version of this
that's a little bit softer which is like
an admin stands up a sort of
starter set of packages that are
essentially
installed and then users can install
their own packages on top of that but
like
they can use the starter set if they
want to so that uh you know it that that
works very easily
there's nothing wrong with doing that
it's totally fine
in most cases it is unnecessary um we
tend to find um you know the the big
reasons people want to do this are
because um they want to
um you know sort of make things easier
for for data scientists to sort of get
started
um in general folks can install the
right if you can library a package you
can install it um
and and if folks are having trouble with
like system level dependencies uh this
is where we sort of recommend
centralizing those resources on a server
as opposed to everybody working
on their own desktop um so again even on
a server
we recommend everybody managing their
own individual libraries not sort of
essentially managed site library
um so that's that's a great question
um here's another great question on um
what does rn saves include all of the
packages that are installed are only
those actually used inside a project
yeah this is a great question
um by default it if you do a snapshot
it snapshots only those packages that
are in use
at the current time and what that means
is that like it can find them somewhere
in like
a library call or a like you know
a colon colon call right if it can find
either of those it will capture those as
as dependencies um this does sometimes
get people into trouble if people are
doing this
um um
[Music]
and then like l apply
uh lib install.packages like
this will not get picked up from our end
and also is a bad process right if
you're doing this
this is just like a plan this says you
need rn
uh so if you're doing this don't do this
use rnv instead it works way better it
captures versions and not just packages
and also doesn't mess up right like this
could mess up somebody's entire package
environment
um if if you turn up there is a way in
our and to turn on
auto snapshotting which is basically any
package that gets installed
will get snapshotted um and and so
uh uh um that can end up being like
more than the packages you actually need
and then there is a prune command
basically
that allows you to prune the rmd library
back to only the things that are
actually being used um
great question let's see
uh do you have a free version of package
manager yes it's the public one
uh our studio package manager packaging
rs2.com is public package manager
if you want something behind your
firewall an internal version
that is where our pro product comes in
so good good question
um package manager for radio control the
list of packages that caches
when will it do the same for python
packages um no guarantee on when
it is under active development uh by the
packet manager team and will be out
shortly uh for those of you who
who aren't quite aware um package
manager um
the the private version um supports pi
python repos pi pi repos um currently
though it only supports full mirrors it
does not support subsets and that sort
of thing
uh this will be forthcoming in future
versions of
package manager what is your
recommendation
to use a mix and this will be the last
question i think we're running out of
time
what is your recommendation to use a mix
of validated public packages in one
environment in a highly regulated market
yeah this is a great
a great question so there are a bunch of
different ways to to
do this the most common way we see this
done
um is oops let me
i'm going to go back to this is our
internal sort of demo version of package
manager
is you can create a validated repository
here
inside our studio package manager and
that can sit aside right like you have
multiple repos
and so like you can do this yourself i'm
showing you in our studio package
manager but you can do this in other
tools this is not an our studio factory
manager's big thing
um but i happen to have an example here
in our studio package manager you can
create a validated repository that has
only those validated packages in it
right and you can specify
the versions and the sort of packages
and you can have that sitting beside
this is a full cram mirror
right and so what you can do then is you
can say like okay for the validated
project
use the validated repository right and
you again just go to the setup tab here
make sure you're using the appropriate
binary repository and if you want to
choose a choose a date
if you want to um and uh if if you're
you if you're doing sort of a
more public project that doesn't need um
you know that that sort of high degree
of validation
just use the sort of all-in public
repository um or
the alternative is you know you could
have the validated for the validated
repository and the public
you could just literally use a public
crown mirror um this isn't quite as
ideal because
uh you know then it's a little easier to
mess up but
um that's sort of the recommendation
there
um i know we did not have time to get to
all the questions here unfortunately
we're
um i think out of time
um i can uh uh
i will be putting together some more
materials on this topic and sort of
emailing them out
so i really appreciate all the questions
i will uh take a look at all these
questions and and we'll probably include
a little faq and some of the
future um documents we we send out and
um we'll try and address as many of
these as as possible
um again really really appreciate
everybody's time today and for sticking
with us
through all the technical difficulties
today i've i've never quite
had a webinar go like this uh but i i
really appreciate everybody sticking
with us
and um hope you you got something out of
the
time today so thanks so much for joining
and look forward to hearing from you
more soon